all right leo
yes yeah where'd you grow up where are
you from originally originally i was
born and raised in corpus christi texas
and uh
lived there to when i was 23 years old
and then uh
i was in prison
for four years
and then i got out
and then
my mom passed away so i moved to
california what was your family like as
a kid
as a kid
my dad
was a great man as far as i know he
he was around till when i was eight
years old and he passed away from colon
cancer
and
as a young kid i was
went through some hard times
my mom became an alcoholic
and i also
went through some hard times where
we were living in the house but
and no
food
no
furniture no nothing
supporting my sister me myself
my mom an alcoholic leaving us there by
ourselves in the house
my mom would come home sometimes at
night with different men
who would uh
molest my sister
and i also was molested when i was
little
and i started
drinking from there
at the age of eight
started smoking weed at the age of eight
tried my cocaine when i was
13 years old
lived a hard life working at the age of
eight years old on the field
after that my mom cleaned up
but i still had my issues where she got
remarried and she had my stepdad who was
i ended up finding out that he was an
alcoholic
and uh
went through some rough times with him
and
uh
where
he would just
take an advantage and
abuse us
as a little kid and i would take it out
and drinking
since i was already drinking you know
uh
and protect my little sister
you know
and
go to school my mom never believed me
when i would tell her
so
i did stuff on my own
and i took care of my sister
finally
they got separated
and it was just me my mom and my sister
my mom is diabetic
she
got one of her toes amputated got her
leg amputated
and
i lived with my mom until
she passed away and uh november 11th
2000
2014
and uh
moved out here to california
but i was doing cocaine
when i was still living in texas
doing cocaine
moved out here found
doing crank out here
i've been doing
drugs
acid pills everything and
i basically tried everything so
but
my worst times were when i was the
crackhead a real bad crackhead
i did a lot of crack i used to buy
cookies what they call cookies i used to
owe my check
to
every friday get my check go give it to
the dope man
give me a cookie be a crackhead
smoking crack
all day long all night long till when i
have to go to work be at work
little breaks here and there
did that for four years
smoke crack
finally one day i just
got tired of it
quit doing crack started doing cocaine
went from cocaine
to crank
cocaine i was doing it in texas moved to
california started doing crank
crystal night yeah well it was called
crank it's like crystal meth
and which they had colors in it which
they were pink or peanut butter you know
and uh
and to me was
it was good you know that because i like
to be up i like to
i was i would work
but i had
my drug addiction
but
to support it i would work
i worked
oh man 70 something hours they would
have to tell me that's quit working
because i was working so much
but i never let the drug
take too much which
at the beginning i did i was so bad that
i was stealing
you know like which i still do you know
i still do it now because i have to
support my habit
but
and crank moved out
crystal meth came in and i now i'm doing
crystal meth i used to snort it at the
beginning
and uh
okay let me get to this
let me i moved to when i was in school
okay i used to be a football player i
used to play baseball football i was an
athletic guy
i was going to get a scholarship
to texas tech
i was getting scouted i went
i was in high school
i used to have scouts come and look at
me
i was a fullback
tell back
wherever you put me i would play
that was me
scholarship comes around what do i do
don't go to it stay with my drug
i leave it like that
screwed it all up
started doing other drugs that's when i
just started doing cocaine started doing
crack all this other stuff
you know what
i could never get rid of it i would
leave one drug to go to another drug
substitute it with another one
and it was like what the heck you know
and like
drinking came along i was always
drinking
i was always doing something
but
i left drinking
when my son came around my son's 13
years old now it's been 13 years that i
haven't drank
but i quit drinking but i still stay
with my meth
she snorted at the beginning
never smoked it
until one day my heist i asked my wife i
said hey man i need some [ __ ] man i
don't have anything she was the only
thing i have is in a pipe i said she
goes but you don't do that i said well
show me how to do it
and i'll do it
so she says this is the way you do it
you just gotta melt it down in here
but don't heat it up too much and you
gotta twist it and i said is that it and
she goes yeah i said okay
did it the first time she goes but don't
hold it in too long
okay
boom i felt this little rush and from
there
that pookie was my best friend i never
left it alone
that i wouldn't not let nobody touch it
i'd clean it up
had it with me all the time never left
it behind
to this day i still do it
but i function i can talk to people i
like talking to people i like
being around people
i like
meeting people i like doing things i'm a
i'm i'm a jack of all trades
i do i know how to work do electrical
work i do welding i do
mechanic work i do all kinds of stuff
i surprise a lot of people because they
see me and they think i
i don't know [ __ ]
i'm not book smart but i'm street smart
i'll tell you that much i know that
i'm not book smart but i'm street smart
and the thing is is this that
the way it is in society is
if you're not supporting your own habit
nobody else is going to do it
so i support my own habit i go to stores
i go
take whatever i need to take to make my
money
to go buy my stuff
so i can have
and this is an everyday thing
this is an everyday thing this is what i
do every day
i make money i hustle
go buy my drugs do my drugs
but i never asked nobody else for help
because i don't want to owe nobody
this is my this is my problem this is my
issue this is the way my life is
when i want to straighten it out i think
it's i'll i'll tell somebody i'll go
look for help
but right now i don't think i want it i
don't think i just want to be where i
want to be yet i know where i want to be
in five years from now
i know where my goals are but
i still not ready for it
so
this is what i'm doing now
and i live out
and
and like i run into so many people and
like these people out here they want to
take my [ __ ] you know they want to jack
me for my [ __ ]
you have to be on your p's and q's all
the time and the p's and q's are like
the most important thing in your life
you know like being on the streets if
you're not on them
they're going to rob you they're going
to take your [ __ ] every [ __ ] time and
it's not
the coolest thing
because you work
your ass off to go [ __ ] take that
[ __ ] and that's so somebody else can
take it from you
no it's not going to work that way
i don't have friends out here i don't
like talking to people i don't like
because your own friends you don't have
friends out here in the streets
these ain't friends
because they steal from you
they'll they'll lie to you laugh in your
face act like they're your friends
as soon as you get off your p's and q's
they take your [ __ ] and you're they're
gone
but they'll come back
when they're done with your stuff
getting rid of your stuff don't come
back and be your friend again saying
that they never took it but knowing them
well that they did
there's people out here that you got to
know
and
those are the people
that
if you're not keeping the tent if you
don't pay attention to them
they're gonna [ __ ] stab you in the
back
all these dope things that are out here
even me
but that's one thing my code is i will
not rat anybody out
i don't do that [ __ ] there's people out
here that rat people out so much that
it's so it's like
horrible man
because they don't want to go get be
inside jail [ __ ] dope sick and all
that
me i won't i'll go do my time come back
out do my do my thing
but you know what
i'll tell you one thing that uh
that i see a lot is uh
people talk about everybody talks even
me
that i want to be clean they want to be
clean
but we don't make an effort
and
it's because we're not ready
and people want us to they want us to do
something that we don't want to do
when we're ready
i think
we'll go to somebody and look for help
your body will tell you hey there's too
much of this you know what
you got to go get help
and you'll go to somebody you'll find
somebody
and you will do this on your own you
don't need nobody else to tell you you
don't need somebody else to come and
tell you hey you know what
go go get cleaned up man
no
when you're ready you'll go do it
yourself and to me it's like
i'm not ready
when i'm ready i'll i'll go to somebody
i know where to go
but i'm not ready i still like i got to
spoke my stuff i still do
you know
like this morning i had to
get my stuff i had to smoke my [ __ ]
before i came out here
people smoke weed to me that's weed me
that's what keeps me moving
if i don't smoke my stuff
like right now i feel like smoking you
know i do
but i know i can't right now
but i know once i leave from here i am
because i feel like smoking already you
know i need it
and
it's like
i already have my [ __ ] already ready so
when i leave from here i already have it
ready i just go take my little tokes and
i'm ready and i'm i'm again i'm a brand
new man
but
i like being out here man i just
there's certain parts of your life that
you go through and and you just have to
uh
people don't understand it unless if
you're an addict if you've been an
addict
or
you've gone through some stuff man you
know and my whole thing started off with
when i was uh molested in
i always blamed myself and then i would
cover it up with the drugs
until this day i still do you know
and uh
you think do you think if that hadn't
happened you may not be here today
i don't yeah
if that hadn't happened
yeah cause uh
these guys would get me drunk
they would get me drunk
and make me
get under my knees
and do things to them
that i didn't want to do
it just [ __ ] me up mentally
never told nobody never told my mom
never told my dad
my sisters my brothers nobody
two years ago my wife found out that i
was molested she never knew
we've been together
going to 16 years
she never knew i never told her
until like i said ben you know i gotta
tell her but what's bothering me you
know so i told her
she goes how come you didn't tell me a
long time ago because i didn't want to
because i didn't think
that's not me that's not a man
but you know what i am a man
because i can tell stories now i can
face people i can tell people that i was
molested i'm not embarrassed
because it wasn't my fault
it wasn't me i didn't make the choice
you're how old i was seven years old six
i started up at five years old until
when i was seven years old
and it wasn't my fault i was thinking it
was my fault but it wasn't
until when i realized it and they told
me it wasn't your fault it wasn't you
you weren't the adult you were a kid
and i don't think if that would have
happened i don't think i would have been
doing this because this
covers up everything
i have a son
that
he's no longer with me he's
social service he took him away
but i was over protected when my son was
around me
i wouldn't let him get near my friends
or
like him lead up against my friends i
would be like because that brought
memories of what happened to me when i
was little
i said hey man hey please don't get
close to my son or son don't get close
to him you know like cause that
to me right away that's what i would
think
i want that to happen to my son
but
when i do drugs i don't think about
nothing
i don't think about pain i don't think
about
what's hurting me inside but when it
goes away
when i'm not high no more it starts
coming back
that's why i do what i do again
so i can forget about it
but i just know it's just a cover-up
that's just the cover-up it's not taking
nothing away
it's just the cover-up
for that moment and that time
and i'm gonna it's gonna keep on
happening until when i
it gets out of my head i don't think it
will
i don't know if i ever will be
clean
i plan to be clean one day but
not in this situation
it's
i i'd rather
i rather
[Music]
i want to get my son back but it's hard
this life is so freaking hard
you got so much things to think about
like stuff that comes around and
you'll be thinking you're doing good and
suddenly just like [ __ ] what just
happened
you just went off the tracks you went
somewhere else
you were doing good not no more
back all over again started everything
again
but the drugs always there
drugs always there that's that's that's
the best thing you can do like for me
it's the best thing i can do so i could
take my pain away so i can take
everything so i can forget about
everything you know
and uh
uh that's
that's what uh
i'm gonna have a normal life one day
one day i just want to have a normal
life
i don't know what normal is i don't even
i don't even think there's a somebody
out there that has a normal knife
because i think everybody has problems
their own way
their own issues
i don't care if you have millions of
dollars
you're not happy still
you're still you're probably going
through the worst things that i have
you know
you probably
these people at movie stars they can't
even step outside of their house they
can't even go to the grocery store
without somebody taking a picture of
them
you know it's like
to me it's uh
it's not about money it's
dealing with that uh with that issue
where i was molested
i think uh
when i take care of that issue i think
everything else would just go away
i think so
it's just uh i don't know what it's
going to happen i don't know how to take
care of it
therapy perhaps
i tried it
and
oh man
i put her through some hell
i blamed her like
i i cussed her out so much it's like
yeah i used to call her [ __ ] [ __ ] i
used to tell her everything every time
she would see me every wednesday she
would see me
she had tears in her eyes
because she knew the way i was why
because she was trying to get this
information out of you the stuff noticed
what it was it was
that
when i went to her she started off
didn't ask me what was my life like
you know it was like
started off way up here on the top like
what at the at the end of my life
already like coming to this
no
i told her why did you start from the
beginning how come you didn't ask me
how was it from the beginning when you
were little when you were born how were
you raised how was your dad how was your
mom or something no you didn't even ask
me that you give me a book and then you
want me to write
however
if i want to write a book i'll go write
a book
i need your help okay ask me what's
going on with me from the beginning of
my life
how did you get to this point
how are you going to know if you don't
ask me i said you started off over here
i said that's why i don't like you i
said i don't i don't what are you here
just for a paycheck or what finding the
right therapist yeah and i was like
i go you know what you give me a book i
said i'm not going to write anything i
said you know what
writing to me is not nothing
me expressing myself and my feelings to
you and telling you the way i feel and
what i'm going through it's better
because you could see it but you can't
see my emotions through the paper
and the writing you don't know what i'm
going through
and like from there on i i didn't like
her and one day i just
seen her one wednesday i said hello how
are you doing
she looks at me and she her eyes got
water i said look i want to apologize i
want to start all over
from the beginning
i'm sorry the way i treated you i'm
sorry the way i talk to you but this is
that's what i felt at that moment but
can we start all over she said yeah it
was probably hard for you to get it off
your chest
yeah and when i started all over from
the beginning
she understood where i was coming from
she goes okay we got to work on this
she's the one that told me was it my
fault what happened to me when i was
little
see that's what i needed how was she
going to know if i was ever molested if
she never asked me
you know way over here but this happened
when i was younger
you know then she started helping me out
started making me understand she goes
speak about it you talk about it
don't hold it in tell people let people
know what what you're feeling you know
it doesn't matter it's not your fault it
doesn't degrade you from being a man
if you were molested there's a lot of
people that been through this
so that's why i'm not scared to tell
people i let people know like hey
i could express it i said yeah i was
blessed when i was little you know and
people and then i've had people come up
while i'm talking to them telling them
that that they say oh i was too
i said is this your first time like
letting somebody know they said
they'll say well no you're about the
second person because i don't tell too
many people
i said it's good it's good to let people
know man you're not the only one you
it's not your fault like the way they
told me
so
to me it's like
once i deal with that issue i think uh
everything else will start falling in
place but right now
i'm gonna
i gotta like
work on that issue that issue is
dealing with
with that militation that they did to me
what they did to me and uh
once i get that
figured out i think everything else is
gonna fall in place like the way it
should be
i gotta have a perfect life you know but
i still gotta
i'm not ashamed of myself
to tell people who what i do or what my
drug
choice is or whatever i'm not i'm not
ashamed
i'm not scared to tell people this is
who i am this is what i am and this is
this is what you get of me
hey i'm not going to change for nobody
you know
i'm 51 years old
51 years old and i'm not going to change
for nobody
uh i got to do it myself
but
if you don't like the way i am i don't
need to talk to you you don't need to
talk to me i'm not asking you to stay
here
but i don't have that many problems
because i i talk to a lot of people i
respect a lot of people
i treat people
like the way i want to be treated and i
think that's where i get
to know a lot of people i've talked to i
talk to a lot of people
and i like that
makes me feel good
you know even though that they don't
know i'm high
but yeah i love it even the cops i talk
to cops all the time they won't even
know i'm higher than high
i'm talking about high i mean like
like
so high but they won't even know they'll
be laughing with me cracking jokes and
everything
and like and i'm like god this guy
doesn't can't even tell that i'm high
and i'm talking to him
because that's the way i am i like
i don't show it
but i do have an issue and
not a shame to say it i'm no better than
nobody else i'm just as equal as
everybody else
uh
no better than that person that's off
the
go off the street i'm no better than him
uh i'm as equal as him
we just live different lifestyles that's
it
and that's the thing that's different
but otherwise
this is me and this is who i'm i am
i'm just a normal person that has an
issue
you can't change it right now but it
will happen but uh
yeah that's me
what are you afraid of the hardest part
of your life
what am i afraid of
oh man i'm afraid of a lot of things
afraid of uh
oh my god
i don't know what
being normal is
that's what i'm scared of
because i think i get up and i i have to
do something because i won't i say to
myself i don't focus in society
without getting high i can't
i can't
and to me it's like
i'm scared to be like normal like
everybody like if i see somebody that
does not do drugs
to be just like them
i try to figure it out how does it feel
to be like that
you know like i've
so many years man
and haven't been clean you know
it's like
how i look at these people and i try to
figure them out i'm like how are they
not doing no drugs how they're not
nothing and they're just like laughing
and happy and
having a joyful time but
i don't get it i don't know i don't
understand i'm scared of being normal
just a an average ordinary person
that's what i'm scared of
what is it about crystal meth that seems
like some people go off the rails very
quickly and other people seem to be more
like yourself where you're you're kind
of
fairly normal well the thing is is this
uh
have you ever gone like
psychotic episode
no to me is this uh
these people that are
doing these drugs doing this
me personally myself when i do it i get
up in the morning
i eat
breakfast then i smoke
then i do my things and i'll be smoking
throughout the day but i'll be eating
and drinking something these people that
are out here they don't eat they don't
drink they gotta sleep and they don't
sleep
but i can sleep
you sleep every night i sleep every
night i see the people that i'm talking
about will go weeks with us yes and i
and those are the people that are noodle
groovy
and those are the people that are
hallucinating
okay i don't i did that at the beginning
of what i used to start when i started
man
okay i used to hallucinate i used to see
thing
and then i started figuring this [ __ ]
out i said well i started noticing when
i'm eating and drinking fluids
this [ __ ] never happens
so i started doing that
and
now that i know i don't need big meals i
eat portions throughout the day
but always drinking something
and i'm fine and i sleep at night
get up in the morning eat breakfast
you know i don't hit the pipe i don't
hit the pookie real quick right in the
morning that's not my thing i gotta eat
something
then i'll do my thing throughout the day
then i go
hustle
bake my buddy so i could have some [ __ ]
so i could have it for the morty and
then i know i have something enough for
me in the morning yeah go do my hustle
again
that's that's the way it is that's the
way it is
you know but don't get me wrong
if
they they need me to work somewhere do
something i'll do it i'll work for
something
you know i don't want nothing to give it
to me for free nothing in this world is
free
you'd have to pay for it somehow some
way
so i don't want nothing given to me for
free i just want
to work for it
i want to say i work my ass for it you
know what i don't need to share my [ __ ]
with nobody it's mine this is what's
what i work for
it's where it is and uh
there's uh people that that can't they
let the drug control them and i
i don't let that happen
i don't let the drug control me i think
the day it does
i think that's the day i need to quit
doing it
but it has me a little bit okay don't
get me wrong it has me because i still
have to do it but i don't have me to
wear
i'm doing crazy ass [ __ ]
we're hallucinating all this other stuff
i know what i'm doing i know where i'm
at i know you're living on the street
yeah
i
i know what i need to do to get to
certain things
but
i choose to live like this this is the
way i choose to live is
to my thing is like i don't have to live
like this
right
i could be living in a place but
this is the way i choose to live man you
know
because i don't need to pay rent
i don't pay no bills no responsibilities
no responsibility but
real life is
you got to pay you got to pay rent you
got to pay bills that's real life real
[ __ ]
but i don't want real [ __ ] yet
that's the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] about this
drug man this life
that's what
i'm not ready for i'm not ready for this
[ __ ] i mean i think having those
responsibilities is what gives your life
meaning yep
and you're living a life that's almost
meaningless
yeah
yeah because i'm just like
i'm supporting something that like
it's nothing
but i know what i'm doing wrong you live
to get your fix and then you go to bed
and you do it again tomorrow yep and
that's that's what i'm doing wrong i'm
doing all this [ __ ] this i'm doing it i
i could say it one way
it sounds good that i'll just [ __ ] go
that other way i do it this was the
wrong way all the time
you know
it's
i have
my wife my wife is like
she does
fit the law
i don't i don't touch that [ __ ] i don't
like it i
me and her do different things and
i
know that if i
me and my wife have to get help you know
but
i just can't leave her like that
and leave her out like that dry you know
my wife is my wife we have kids together
i can't just leave her just and go get
help for myself i know it's supposed to
be me myself and i
i got to work on myself first before i
do anything else
if i don't fix myself up i'm never gonna
do nothing
but uh
i can't help somebody else i can't fix
somebody else up but to me it's like
if i can't fix myself up
why am i worried about somebody else you
know
i can't do it for myself i can't do it
for nobody else if you're working on
somebody else and not yourself
what the [ __ ] is the whole [ __ ] about
them
you know why he doing it then you know
to me it's like
work on yourself i think
that's my issue my number one thing i
think i have to do is
have to work on myself
it's me myself and i that's it and if i
get those correct and i do it the right
way
i think i can
beat this and
live
want to say not a normal life but
a family life
still with a little bit of issues but
not a drug issue
you know still have your little problems
you know
but uh
i think i can do that but i don't know
what is going to happen
that's the thing that
screws me up so bad i want to do so many
things
i can't overwhelm myself i got to do one
thing at a time if i overwhelm myself
never going to get nothing good
never
so i have to just
i don't know
whatever i'll see again maybe if i see
you again maybe it'll be different
maybe i'll be on a
where
i could say hey i haven't touched this
in so many years you know
but uh
this is who i am
this is what i
do
and uh
not embarrassed
i'm not ashamed
but
it's my life
i have a lot of stuff on the plate you
know i went through a lot of stuff
but uh
one thing out of time
and it'll happen and it'll just
come through
i think i
i'll be better
i think i'll have my kids back
i hope so
yeah
all right leo thank you so much for
sharing i wish you the best of luck okay
you